i think we can all agree that the movie
industry right now is going through a
seismic shift
and um movie theaters are in trouble um
and i'm curious for your on your
thoughts
do you think that movie theaters are are
going to survive
and if so are they just going to be
event pictures
all right let's where do you where do
you live steve i'm just curious
los angeles where movie theaters have
been yeah
right okay even in los angeles it's a
bit hard to go to the movies isn't it
it's you gotta drive you gotta park uh
you gotta be there at a very certain
time i mean i love the arc light there's
one in
hollywood there's one not too far away
from where i live
um there's also a theater that was open
that was charging 27
a seat so then people could would bring
you the nachos and they didn't even have
a snack bar that you could stand in line
you had to pay 27
and you had to order from somebody which
means as you're watching rocket man as i
did
somebody comes by and says can i get you
some more cheese on your nachos
no i'm good man i'm just watching the
movie i paid 27
there are there's there's there is this
reality
of of uh
the viability of of exhibiting movies
that is that has been based on the
desire of people to see the movie now in
new york city where i am right now
i think new york is one of the easiest
places to go to the movies
you can decide to go to the movies and
be in the theater a half hour later
you can walk to one you know there's
enough screens around when
when the movies are open of course that
you can go up and actually have a
plethora of choices
even though those choices might only be
the 12 movies that are playing
you know nationally at any given time um
this
goes a long way to say that a sea
change was due anyway
um it was coming um the fact
is that there is let me okay
i don't want to take up too much time on
this answer but let me tell let me tell
you this story
when i was a kid and the abc
sunday night movie played the first half
of david lean's bridge over the river
kwai
in pan and scan in 133
with commercials i was still convinced
that the bridge over the river kwai was
one of the greatest motion pictures i
had ever seen
and it was as primitive a display as
possible it might have even been in
black and white
i don't think we had a colored
television the first time i was on and
he had to watch it the second time
that he had to watch the second half on
monday night the school night
that didn't take away from my enjoyment
of bridge over the river quiet
i didn't even know that there was
limitations on it
now we're of course with netflix and and
all the streaming services
we have we have the ability to sit and
watch a movie anytime we want to on our
couch
if the movie is really great and
engaging you can still come away from
that experience thinking that was one of
the greatest motion pictures i have ever
seen
i've experienced that just recently with
chernobyl uh the five-part thing i said
i
like that was one of the greatest motion
pictures i've ever seen and it comes
across on some other
other films as well will movies
movie theaters still exist absolutely
they will
uh in some ways uh i think the
exhibitors once they're
once they're up and open are going to
have a freer choice to what movies they
do want to play
but i'm going to i'm and i'm no
cassandra when it comes down to this but
i'm gonna say that
big event motion pictures are going to
rule the day at the cinemas
um there's a type of film that is about
you know
it could even be the case um the uh um
news of the world might be the last kind
of like adult movie about people saying
interesting things
uh that's gonna play on a big screen
somewhere because after this
uh in order to guarantee that people
show up again we're gonna have the
marvel universe and all sorts of
franchises
and some of those movies are great you
want to see them um writ large
because actually uh watching it at home
on your couch actually might diminish
them somewhere
uh somehow uh in in their in their in
their visual punch
but the sea change that has been
wrought by covid 19 has been a slow
train coming i think there will be an
awful lot of movies
that will only be streamed and it will
be fine to see them that way
because they're actually built and made
and constructed
for somebody's pretty you know pretty
good screen
widescreen tv at their home and there
will be other movies
that are going to be playing in that
window uh and
people will in fact i think flock to
them in order to see them on the big
screen while they
while they have the chance but without a
doubt um
we're we're we are actually into the
the big curve of change um that's uh
that i think has been due ever ever
since people
uh you know first have the ability to
what is it called pvod pain pay for
video on demand
ever since that started up actually it
probably you can maybe argue
ever since the vhs cassette tape um
uh was first introduced in a cheap way
um this is uh this has been uh this has
been
just across the horizon